[Music]
learning keeps me going in my 34 years
of career i have seen many things the
course which i did in simply learn has
helped me come closer to my
dream of building a artificial
intelligence-based multi-million dollar
empire yeah hi i'm manoj majumdar i live
in delhi and i work for nugent software
technologies limited as vice president
channel sales in the last 11 years i
have set up a partner network around 70
countries around the world my job is to
take my team along and create a network
of partners kill them nurture them and
make them ready for selling in the
global market over the past 34 years i
have seen various technologies evolving
starting from doors to windows to unix
to linux to
mainframe computers i've seen them all
and now the new thing which is coming up
is artificial intelligence i took up the
course
of ai for decision making in live what
offered and organized by simply learn
and i think now that i couldn't have
taken up any other course
which could have done so much of justice
and i think it's a great course the
course has been designed in a way
wherein you don't need to be a
programmer you don't actually need to be
even an i.t professional to understand
this course plus what they have done is
they have divided the course into
multiple small small sections in every
section you have a test they have
explained it in a very simple way they
have explained it linking it to the
business because it is self-paced it
really helps you learn
the way you want to the pace which you
want to follow and it does not really
disturb your family life or your
official life
so i also had a
dream to do my own business in fact i
have tried doing it twice before and
this will be my third attempt and i
thought of doing good by
using artificial intelligence so what i
think of is using this artificial
intelligence learning and use it in
different
software tools which we use or we create
and help them sell not just in india but
in the global market i wrote this book a
few months back the book titled islam
leading lines why we don't have a google
or microsoft from india i wrote this
book because you know i always thought
that we in india do so much of work in
software
and our guys go go out and they had
google they had microsoft they had ibm
but when it comes to india we don't have
a single billion dollar product company
and this became a
bestseller in amazon this became a hot
seller for more than a month all big
journeys
start with a small step
and i think upskilling is one of them
[Music]